but actually go back to the overtime
that earlier which is humility and how
it relates to forgiveness and I think
that it's possibly you and people
actually might differ on your
perspective of forgiveness in that
retirement us yesterday intersection do
you need do you need to have further you
know have a policy offered to grant
forgiveness or can you grant forgiveness
without someone being willing to to sort
say oh I've committed an act that you
know I need to ask for forgiveness for I
mean that's part of you I think I think
I would say that the true forgiveness is
not a kind of bargain in the end you
know I'm prepared to forgive you because
you now said you're really sorry being
so bad topic of you and you know it's
not i mean my experience with with
complex situations it it has to be
something you're initiating from within
yourself so now forgiveness as such
because it's not you know keep saying
saying I'm going to forgive you sort of
sure there's an arrogance about that
yeah I amazon forgiveness implies
obviously that you believe that you have
been wrong but i think it's i use the
term forgiveness honest in the sense of
putting putting to one side what has
happened you know letting the the
positive day I mean you know what Barry
stocks are saying moment to do a go on
the perpetrator you know the willingness
to recognize mean I think that's all
bound in in with it as well and you know
we can we can try and divide up these
different emotions i think they add
together the you no sense of humility a
sense of forgiveness and a sense that
you're prepared to acknowledge you too
may have done wrong i actually one of
the most interesting moments in the
northern iron process was when i said to
you actually these were
leggins you know about about Reverend
Paisley you know what he why don't you
just trust him and this is fun look to
trust him they just hidden but actually
you know that was part in the end of
what we've got it through now I think
all of those emotions have to be linked
in to that but I so maybe forgiveness
i'm using there's a bit of a shorthand
there but but i think it at the minimum
its willingness to put the past behind
you